let's have a look inside the token
classification pipeline
in the pipeline video we looked at the
different applications the transformers
library supports out of the box one of
them being token classification
for instance predicting for each word in
a sentence
whether they correspond to a person an
organization or location
we can even group together the tokens
corresponding to the same entity for
instance all the techns that form the
word silver here are aging and phase
the token classification pipeline works
the same way as the text classification
pipeline we studied in the previous
video there are three steps the
tokenization
the model and the post processing
the first two steps are identical to the
text classification pipeline except we
use a neutral token classification model
instead of a sequence classification one
we tokenize our texts then feed it to
the model
instead of getting one number for each
possible label for the whole sentence we
get one number for each of the possible
nine labels for every token in the
sentence here 19.
like all the other models of the
transformers library our model outputs
logits which we need to turn into
predictions by using a softmax
we also get the predicted level for each
token by taking the maximum prediction
since the softmax function preserves the
orders we could have done it on the
legits if we had no need of the
predictions
the modal conflict contains the level
mapping in its id to level field using
it we can map every token to its
corresponding label
the label o corresponds to no entity
which is why we didn't see it in our
results in the first slide
on top of the label on the probability
those results included to start an n
character in the
sentence we'll need to use your state
mapping of the tokenizer to get those
look at the video link below if you
don't know about them already
then
looping through each token that has a
level distinct from o we can build the
list of results we got with our first
pipeline
the last step is to group together
tokens that correspond to the same
entity
this is why we have two labels for each
type of entity
hyper and b-pair for instance
it allows us to know if a token is in
the same entity as the previous one
note that there are two ways of labeling
used for token classification one in
pink here uses the b-bar label at the
beginning of each new entity but the
other in blue only uses it to separate
two adjacent entities of the same type
in both cases we can flag a new entity
each time we see a new label appearing
either with the i or b prefix
then take all the following tokens
labeled the same with an i flag
this coupled with the offset mapping to
get the start and hand characters allows
us to get the span of text for each
entity